uccisi e ovvio come è rimasto nova belle
gare play della tutti ragazzi prevenuti
questo video sono famigerata ci siamo su
se entro 4 che è un videogame figure si
vede un secolo centro non solo che non
lo zio oscar e che altri ragazzi un
salvataggio da internet con il gioco già
completo così da poter passeggiare come
si deve io che figo per milan ci voglio
provare la spada
dove è finito scusi lei mi faccio a
provare che una squadra un secondo ecco
ebbe carina che ha seguito la fanno
parte della mia gang lo scemo io perché
è un esalta penn aria
in realtà ragazzi c'è stata un'invasione
aliena infatti questi sono alieni in
teoria e io cioè i poteri tipo di di
superman
se io posso cos'è cuore perché posso
volare che se qual è il senso di questa
cosa non chiedetemi come né perché a
possono gettare il pugno tipo
smaterializzato in campo d onore lurido
maniaco cos'è
cos'ha fatto avevo fatto fermare no
vagheggi ma neanche john cena vaste cosa
ma pensavo ci fossero rimosse speciali
che film che ho fatto è l'amato è ma
dentro il cestino arrivabene gara calmi
cos'è è bellissimo è una fiaba anche sul
posto si sta temi bersaglio tipo questo
addio bravo frate bravo zio fermati
voglio darti un premio voi date un
premio
ecco il premier a trovarti parcheggio e
ce l'ho fatta non ha il parcheggio buono
lontano andare il parcheggio è buono zio
non te ne andare che non lo trovi più
non è castiglioni livello che anche solo
correndo io le cose le spazzo via così
ferma la voglia voglio questa cosa ferma
lì così si fa con le macchine altro che
su gta ma è sicuro qui da queste cose
non perché non mi se
è la madonna che in realtà ragazzi le
armi di questo salvataggio sono un
fucile bello e non è un semplice
lanciarazzi ragazzi ma è un lanciarazzi
come cazzo fatto bene a figo no non
addio non ai capitani questa la voglio
io la voglio io allora subito fermi che
devo fare il culo asta tizio posso
sappiate sopra le navicelle adesso sì
adesso l'ho preso ok ci siamo è i tagli
dal cason sert sui veicoli
ma cos'è varava fermi un'inter non
intendevo fare quella vera sempre figo
comunque sia l'ho presa no non ci credo
sono sicuramente addio e buon viaggio
ragazzi sono riuscito a prendere sta
roba non chiedetemi come march che figo
no vabbè rega è stupendo fatemi fare
slalom tra i pali io son riuscito a
prenderla non ci credo disastro mancata
sarebbe che non mi devo schiantare ma vi
giuro che ho provato a passarci in mezzo
ma non ci sono riuscito a pazienza devo
riuscire a no ma [ __ ] ribelle che è
anti fisica il 2000 per cento per kate
oriali dovrei cadere e morire
distruggermi possiamo fare il tipo
independence day
no perché non posso andare più su dico
sì o no no no no stai fermo che ho
sbagliato di sotto vabbè rega va beh
ecco qua si aggiungono livelli di prua
gine ficazione mica neanche in star wars
eccole l'altra lurida
medei vedeva da fuoco may day
vabbè che salvataggio incredibile creata
sei dovuto morire 600 volte ma vabbè io
sono io la spada laser tipo star wars
non potete nulla contro il potere di io
che scrivo a chiarini quasi picchiasse
lo prendevo che salve lei è un cane
spararti chissà che non si no
ma è passata sopra una macchina non so
cosa è successo
sono morto sono morto comun que ragazzi
ho visto un attimino come funziona
quindi posso fare le cose più seriamente
tipo più guidare le [ __ ] in mezzo
alla strada se vuoi [ __ ] questa
volta è la tua [ __ ] la vuoi venire a
prendere vieni a prendertela vieni a
prendermi e mi vieni a prendere che ti
spacco tutto il ruolo della macchina
vieni a reti frate io ti voglio bene
credimi ma non puoi non puoi
assolutamente andare in giro con quei
capelli li c'e veramente mi fai salire
il john cena esatto questo a questo è
meglio di una cena work a eva che calcio
mistral e nando perché devo entrare nel
manchester city mi faccia da pallone per
cortesia ecco o meglio di bomba
l'autobus l'autobus l'autobus mica
quante volte l'ho preso così per andare
a scuola autobus a pendolo facendoci
surf sopra fermi tramite anni per
mettere ci sono gli fai fare eccolo qui
posso fare anche va beh posso anche fare
la verticale chi minchia volatilizzato
il mio autobus macchine questa carnica
voglio togliti dalla mia vita
grazie al cloud infatti odio e ho
parcheggiato signori o parcheggiate io
anche solo correndo mi porto dietro la
gente se non sto facendo niente solo
correndo e bellissimo tanto ci vorrei
andare così damiano di giuro che non
l'avevo neanche visto giorno mentale lei
con lo scudo ha perso questo io regalo
ecco perfetto chissà che è ancora vivo
com'è possibile
minchia albè che non faccia caso a me
che sono un uomo che salta lei pietro
faccia caso al cane che potrebbe gli
orgogli l'ho detto è la telecinesi devo
provare tutti i tasti per vedere quali
di questi funziona con la telecinesi
fermi un attimo non è esattamente questo
che abbiamo sentito che cosa fa mica che
tipa a zio e zia e non hai capito così
tn fa e le mie migliorate mi difendo
[ __ ] è socia spara liga o lo zio
jolo chi ha o no cazzola buona la musica
tutti io io come è rimasto ora per gare
play
[Musica]
all
no vabbè posso correre in verticale
gioco dell'anno ragazzi a parte ma
perché tipo cioè il simbolo della
fiorentina non trovo giusto di latta
queste firenze non lo sapete parchi
discesista rodano affermi tutte star è
sta roba da contro qualcuno se becco
qualcuno in strada rido da un filotto
l'esagerazione totale disastro fa la cu
li mortacci sua
ciao tu mi porti su e poi mi lasci che
ecco mi porti su e poi mi spacchi in
sedere è la madonna vince antigravità
addirittura anti gravità e spettacolare
fermi un attimo si amalgamava figo gira
gratis offro io sono altro
cosa farò che firmava diventare i
prossimi la e la gente piccola posso
prenderla lo stesso con ostaggio la
schiaccia c'è qualcosa che fa diventare
la gente scena ma a giudicare dai
capelli lo siete già male che tu con la
smart sta fermo fermo devo fuggire
devo fuggire insieme a te non vedo
veicolo più sicuro della smart infatti 6
marzo prossimo ragazzi state casi gesù
santo a stato della libertà non fatemi
andare vi prego consigliamo ci sto
arrivando con non so quale fisica però
ci sto arrivando
perfetto prof siamo arrivati
cosa ci faccio qui perché mi sento un
fenomeno qualcuno voglia di spiegarmi
perché cristiano state stand giochi
scusi non vorrei potete dirmi per
cortesia se questo è un bug del gioco se
è normale che sia così che cosa minchia
17 persone hanno visto persone vere non
ti lascio ti lascio tranquillo ma voi
ragazzi e non è tanto scusa zio
giuro che non volevo è stato un caso
assurdo e volevo dirvi allora io in
realtà ho preso fin troppo perché volevo
giocare ad un dlc di sé in trovo che
sarebbe auto save questo the saints 6
christmas come i sensi salvano al natale
in realtà volevo giocare a questo qui
solo che mi sono preso a cazzeggiare è
che i ragazzi ho fatto un video dove
cazzeggia nel prossimo episodio farò
questa che fa una ministoria vabbè
ragazzi ci proverà nel prossimo episodio
per ora concludo qui il video
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
e cosa sento se vi è piaciuto al momento
è un mi piace anche a pagina di facebook
ercolani vi adottata nella sezione senza
che si scateni ci vediamo un passo vito
e larghezze